President Trump could reach a
breakthrough trade deal with China in
coming weeks the two sides are said to
be getting closer to an agreement that
would end the standoff that has kept
much of the world economy on edge
correspondent Kevin cork is at the White
House tonight with specifics what we
know what we don't good even Kevin
evening bright increasingly optimistic
White House officials tell Fox News that
the talks with China frankly are making
progress but they also cautioned there
are still some issues that remain that
could impact both the pace and the
timing of a resolution I'm dealing with
China right now in a very big trade deal
as you probably have read heard some of
you are a little bit involved while he
was busy welcoming athletes and state's
attorneys general to the White House
today president Trump's top economist
was welcoming a noticeable improvement
in trade talks with China those folks
are working really really hard to
deliver a deal that's you know way north
of a hundred pages now filled with lots
of nuances and details and I think
everybody's hopeful as markets are that
this is going to get to the finish line
sometime soon soon could mean an end of
March meeting at mar-a-lago with Chinese
President Xi Jingping and while no date
has been cemented the president has
instructed his Trade Representative to
inform the Federal Register tomorrow of
his intention to keep tariffs on 200
billion dollars worth of Chinese goods
at 10 percent
until further notice despite positive
movement in the talks gaps remain
including major differences in how China
levies fees on US exports of natural gas
autos and AG products the latter of
which is subject to a whopping 70%
tariff on Twitter the president said
he'd asked China to remove those levies
since he didn't increase tariffs to 25
percent on March 1st but amid the
progress there's still healthy
skepticism we want a verifiable
agreement that will have massive
retaliation if they don't live up to
their deal because every promised China
has ever made they violated they've
never lived up to any of this we've been
talking with them for 30 years on
Capitol Hill the president is facing a
potential revolt among Senate
Republicans over his decision to declare
a national emergency over his
long-promised border wall Kentucky's
Rand Paul is the latest to break
Frank's saying he'll support a measure
to restrict the president's use of
executive power a move that will force
President Trump to use his veto pen for
the very first time I will vote for the
motion to disapprove of this and I will
continue to speak out I do believe that
there is at least 10 Republican no votes
you see possibly more Verret Senate
Majority Leader Mitch McConnell will
likely bring a vote on that resolution
to the floor probably before the 15th of
March recess we're told by our Chad
program it'll likely happen on the 14th
now Democrats could try to override a
possible veto but to get that done they
need 67 votes and our sources tell us
they don't have anywhere near that many
right now Bret Kevin coracle on the
North Lawn Kevin thanks